le chaos se répand dans le monde, nous avons
toujours pensé que la vie extraterrestre viendrait
des étoiles, mais elle venait des profondeurs de
la mer un portail entre les
dimensions de l'océan Pacifique
quelque chose là-bas nous avait découverts
les seuls humains comptés à se cacher pour
abandonner pour échouer à
initier  opérations de lancement
danger gitan ils n'ont jamais considéré notre capacité
à supporter des jumeaux nous relèverions le
défi
pilotes prêts à se connecter allons pêcher
- et une pause générale puis pour activer
le Jaeger
aujourd'hui au bord de notre espoir à la fin
de notre temps
nous  avons choisi de croire l'un en l'autre
aujourd'hui nous affrontons les monstres à notre porte
aujourd'hui nous annulons l'apocalypse
vous